russian aggression is europe's new
normal that's according to nato which is
considering sending more troops to
central and eastern europe but will the
plan protect the continent or worsen
tensions with moscow this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
mohammad jim zhum we face a crisis in
european security that's the warning
from nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg says the threat of russia
invading ukraine shows moscow is
prepared to use force to undermine the
core principles of the western military
alliance
for its part russia says its troops are
now pulling back it released videos of
convoys leaving crimea which russia
annexed from ukraine in 2014 but instead
of pulling out the us argues another 7
thousand russian soldiers have arrived
at the border with ukraine
stoltenberg says europe needs stronger
defenses he's proposed sending more
soldiers to central and eastern europe
as part of new nato battle groups
i think what we are seeing now
is a kind of new normal for european
security
because we have seen this trend over
many years
where russia contests fundamental
principles
for european security
and where there are uh
and
where they're willing to
to to use force as they've done against
ukraine georgia but also to threaten uh
with the use of force to intimidate uh
countries in in europe
a battle group is the main forward block
of an army's fighting force it's usually
made up of about 1500 soldiers
nato deployed combat-ready battle groups
to estonia latvia lithuania and poland
in 2014 after russia annexed ukraine's
crimea region
in total there are more than 4 600
multinational troops in the baltic
states and poland an attack on any of
them would be considered an attack on
nato
those army units hold regular exercises
including the annual winter camp which
is one of nato's largest military drills
with around 1400 soldiers taking part
all right let's bring in our guests in
brussels teresa fallon the founder and
director of the center for russia europe
asia studies
in belfast alexander titov a lecturer at
queen's university belfast who
specializes in russian foreign policy
and in the estonian capital talin cadre
leak a senior policy fellow at the
european council on foreign relations
whose research focuses on russia eastern
europe and the baltic region a warm
welcome to you all and thanks for
joining the program today theresa let me
start with you so nato secretary general
jens stoltenberg says that russian
aggression is the new normal for europe
what exactly does this mean
i think in today's press conference
after the ministerial meeting here at
nato headquarters in brussels
that they're expecting a long drawn out
high pressure tactics from russia so
this is not something that these
exercises are going to wind up uh as the
russians are pretending but he expects
it to be a very long drawn out
uh
experience so this means that
we're seeing kind of a challenge to the
helsinki
agreements
back in 1975 that the soviet union
signed as well as western countries and
this is kind of challenging uh you know
don't change borders through power moves
and putin is really pushing hard to do
said that we might be returning back to
yalta just kind of the spheres of
influence and i think one of the most
telling signs is that troops all the way
from
russia's far east are moved
towards ukraine border which means that
there's a taste and tasted agreement
between
moscow and beijing on
to cooperate on this and i think that
sends a very worrying sign to the rest
of the world this kind of russia china
cooperation
alexander um let's look at this from the
perspective of the russians when
russian president vladimir putin hears
yen stoltenberg used the phrase new
normal that this is the new normal for
europe
what's his viewpoint what does putin
think of that
well i think putin would say that uh
we've been warning you for many many
years
uh uh that uh there are problems we want
to kind of deal with them you can't just
brush our concerns aside uh and now um
you haven't listened to us now you can
have to waste this new normal and so far
as putin is concerned i've been
investing lots of money into uh the army
the navy and so forth uh and also kind
of willing to use them and have having
used them already uh he is more happy
with this new norm than europeans i
think he can pressurize them into
engaging with russia on things which are
important to russia uh and which have
previously been ignored so i think it's
not um
so far as putin is concerned i'm not not
saying it's a good thing but uh things
from point of view of moscow very happy
with that
cadre so we know now that nato is
considering these new battle groups in
southeastern europe in response to
russian military buildup um of course
there are battle groups that exist in
baltic countries they've been there
since 2014 as a response to russia's
annexation of crimea have these battle
groups that were placed there by nato in
baltic countries
worked in
practice well that is hard to answer
because
we don't know what would have happened
without them
but what i can say
is of course they have made the
countries feel
more secure
there are different opinions as to
how and why the baltic states are even
endangered by what russia is is doing
some people in the baltic states think
that when russia occupies ukraine it
will move to the baltic states next
i don't belong in bad camp uh i don't
think that russia really has ambitions
to gain control of the baltic states
or to restore the soviet union or
anything like that
but i think that if tensions reach a
boiling point in any other theater be it
ukraine or
syria or wherever
tensions between
western and russia
reach new heights then actually an
accidental clash in mobordik region
cannot be excluded or
russia making use of the baltic
territory as a place where to signal its
displeasure with nato's stance elsewhere
and i think to ensure against such
incidents the troops here have been very
useful indeed teresa i saw you nodding
along to some of what cadre was saying
did you want to jump in well i think
that
putin would not attack any nato member
because that would trigger article 5. so
i think
as kadri noted though when you have so
many troops there is a high incidence of
possible
accident
so even today we saw in the donbas there
was a shelling of a school so i think
that uh the troop movements are
signaling reassurance but also hopefully
deterrence and there are concerns of
spillage and if god forbid there is some
sort of conflict in ukraine because i
have to be prepared for the worst that
these uh
troops are sent there to kind of
strengthen the border and prepare for
possible millions of refugees moving
from from ukraine so i think that
tensions are extremely high and the fact
that they even met with georgia as the
georgian minister as well as the
ukrainian minister today signals that
they're not backing down nato's not
backing down on their open door policy
which i think must irritate moscow
theresa let me also follow up with you
about the issue of these battle groups
when it comes to the potential creation
and deployment of more nato battle
groups what kind of time frame do you
think we're looking at i think it will
take a little while but i think they're
you know they're moving they already
have this kind of rotational um approach
so they have
one third of the time with nato one
third of the time with the eu and then
one third of the time with their own
national uh group so i think it's a
multinational uh function and it it
wouldn't take too long i don't imagine
that it would take very long to really
get it up and running uh lloyd austin
also spoke about that today at the press
conference uh and i think that they're
talking about a couple of weeks so it
remains to be seen um
but i don't think that it would take
that long really there is a urgency here
alexander wouldn't the creation of these
new battle groups really just further
antagonize russia i mean what can we
expect as a response from russian
president putin
well i think there are there are a whole
series of issues uh which russians are
unhappy about
the troops battle groups which are
really as you know we say any more kind
of nominal um confidence boosting in you
know in the baltic states themselves in
poland rather than you know any threat
to russia or any even any um
real um
uh barrier to russian invasion if it
ever came to that uh is not the main
issue i think kind of issues of uh nato
in further enlargement uh in ukraine
georgia uh but also nato cooperation and
military support uh for ukraine is
something much more worrying for russia
they want to make it much wider than uh
than ukraine but ukraine is still the uh
the core concern of them i mean so
before they can deal with
things which are already inside nato
which russia has no interest and they
accepted that um the countries we joined
nato have joined uh the issue for them
really big one is uh is it security of
uh
cooperation with with ukraine and you
know as putin was saying ukraine has a
disputed territory with russia and
crimea there is ongoing uh conflict in
east donbass and so forth and generally
there is very kind of
anti-hostile to russia
government
and public opinion in ukraine uh which
um they also have about so they want to
make sure that that thing uh that
country ukraine in terms of its uh
military capability does not feel uh
kind of powerful enough to try to solve
those issue outstanding issues with
russia and i think that's much more
important than any any kind of territory
battle groups which nato might put
itself in romania or bulgaria and so
forth cadre i know you touched on this
somewhat in your previous answer but i
want to just try to dig in a little bit
deeper and ask you what are some other
lessons that can be learned when it
comes to nato battle groups in baltic
states
um some other lessons um
now i
i must agree with what
alexander says i uh
i think russia understands what that is
about
i haven't heard anyone
syria's in moscow ever claim that
race troops represent the threat to
moscow
they know that reese are here as a
result of russia's own actions
they came
or maybe boosted after annexation of of
crimea and they are still nominally on
rotational bases which means that nato
actually adheres to the letter of the
nato russia founding act from 97 but
requires not the base permanent troops
here
so to be honest i
i think that
works fairly well the only thing that i
have recommended to the baltic leaders
is that
we are on the nato umbrella we are
protected we are fine but
it might be good to have some bilateral
communication channels also with moscow
if something happens and things have
happened
there was a case when russian fighter
chet
crashed the lithuania there was a case
when spanish plane lost a missile where
estonia you know incidents like greece
that have no evil intent behind them but
that can create confusion and especially
when tensions elsewhere are high uh
people might get suspicious so it would
actually be quite good if you have some
phone number in moscow be it among the
political or military leadership
but you can dial if if something like
that happens because communication
channels via nato headquarters they work
too
and sakura grassy mob link between
military chiefs
but it might be handy to have some
bilateral
communication channel as well alexander
um based on what cadre was just saying
there that she thinks that uh some type
of bilateral communication channel
with moscow uh would be appropriate do
you think that's something that would
work
well it might work and i certainly won't
do any harm if there was one uh that
would be very helpful um issue with the
baltic states i so far as russia is
concerned is not so much uh military
threat from them or from
their allies being based there uh but
it's more kind of what uh russians see
as a very um strong anti uh russian
rhetoric and uh actions coming out of
the baltic states and have which you
know been a consistent theme in uh you
know russian foreign policy discourse
that they are this kind of activists
anti-russian activists which pushing
european union and nato into much more
stringent anti-russian uh direction uh
you know
sending weapons to ukraine i think
estonia sends on weapons lithuania been
sending weapons and so forth uh you know
all those things basically kind of
rattle russians and um uh
kind of that doesn't doesn't help with
uh with the kind of overall uh trust
between them but yeah establishing uh
direct links in case there's a there's a
incident happening and making sure that
it doesn't develop into anything uh more
substantial it would be a good thing but
uh there is a lot of um
annoyance and mistrust on each side
between the baltic states and the
russian which you know doesn't help
overall security i suppose teresa looked
to me like you were reacting to some of
what alexander and also what cadre was
saying did you want to jump in as well
sure
that when uk defense minister ben
wallace was
on his uh recent visit to moscow he also
talked about creating a communication
channel because there's so much
disinformation going on now and that's
the key thing for military men to have
clear communication so i think that
his russian counterparts were rather
open to that and i would also add that
even though there's heightened tensions
in the region
uh
moscow doesn't even have to invade to
destroy the ukrainian economy we see
flights are not landing
or they're not
in ukrainian airspace so this
curtails a lot of uh trade and economic
issues plus they can cause uh problems
in the black sea we've seen them try to
blockade the black sea so there are a
lot of issues that ukraine is can suffer
under without any sort of direct attack
um it's already hurting the economy and
as many people have pointed out there's
russian intelligence uh all through the
ukraine all through ukraine so uh this
can cause mischief so there's really
heightened tensions ukraine could be
suffering this for months neither at war
and neither at peace
cadre from your vantage point um
is there a growing sentiment right now
that
the moves that nato
is making
could perhaps make europe more dangerous
uh no
i don't think so
um
at least as concerns the immediate um
stuff military uh
reinforcements
i think with that everything is um
is is fine and and logical um i think
moscow knows what it is and
but that is not an issue
i think what could become an issue is um
if really the west totally refuses to
engage with moscow
on any other clauses that moscow has
raised
the future of ukraine which is not of
course the west to decide um but it's
linked to wider questions about the
european security order
and
you know the western
position right now is that we have paris
charter that is the
founding document for european security
order that gives each country right to
choose their own alliances and all is
fine with that just but russia doesn't
follow it
i wonder if if that position is really
sustainable just like that
because that order you know it was
agreed
in the early 90s in 1990 when actually
russia subscribed to western values
norms worldview
russia shared it and and that's why
paris charter that actually includes
some contradictory clauses
right of countries to choose their own
alliances and it forbids countries to
enhance their security at the expense of
other countries and risk too can
actually simultaneously be true only if
a continent at large is sort of at peace
and we are not there any longer i mean
russia has made it quite clear that it
doesn't share the world view of the west
so
what i worry a little bit
is
this unwillingness i see in many western
countries too to accept that as a as a
reality
we think we can moralize it into going
away
i don't think that is the case um
so in order to defend the order we like
we should have much better leverage in
in place some actual leverage rather
than just normative notions however good
they are
and
and i don't think we are that mentally
uh yet
so
and where i can see a sort of
danger but
if we insist on
reality that moscow doesn't treat this
reality then
it could be dangerous in the longer run
alexander um secretary general
stoltenberg uh has said that russian
videos of troop pull out that they don't
show meaningful de-escalation
and he added the troop numbers go up and
down but there's a trend of russia
sending more troops over the long run um
from your perspective do you think we're
going to see that do you think we're
going to see more troops added in the
long run or do you think there will be
a de-escalation
or perhaps a meaningful de-escalation in
the in the next few days well i'm not
sure about the next few days so far as
kind of messages from most concerns um
uh they have been uh since monday been
sounding like they were they wanted to
pursue a more kind of diplomatic track
uh with meeting with lavrov uh putin um
kind of agreed to that diplomacy might
still work and after that there was
followed
announcements of troops withdrawals
i think
there is issue of
ukraine is not going to go away and
russia
feeling that it has a military
predominance in the region uh which
probably is one of its main uh
cards to play um will will will be uh
willing to use it again and not in terms
of outright invasion but in terms of
intimidation and both incredible threat
uh towards ukraine uh and that will uh
continue to go on until there are kind
of real movements on uh issue of
ukraine's
membership of nato or rather
non-membership of nato so far as moscow
is concerned the minsk accords and also
broader
limits uh discussion on limits on
military copyright cooperation between
nato and ukraine that moscow wants to
make sure that uh nato through the back
door even without membership builds up
military capacity for ukraine so it can
challenge russia's predominance in the
region
teresa secretary general stoltenberg has
also said that um
in addition to saying that he's seen no
meaningful sign of russian de-escalation
on the ground um he had added that he
did does see um signs of optimism i mean
what do you make of that are there
actually reasons to be optimistic right
now
well i think that was the whole idea
that they had pursued dialogue
and to get dialogue they should have
been de-escalating so they they were
kind of signaling we saw this with
president macron's visit to moscow he
was signaling that the russians were
de-escalating and he got this agreement
from them and all we saw was increased
escalation so there's been a steady
trip
path beaten to moscow's door with world
leaders uh european leaders speaking to
president putin or their counterparts
lavrov and it's almost like they're
playing with them that there has been no
de-escalation and i think that
that really kind of shows that the
kremlin's not serious about dialogue and
that was kind of you know dialogue means
exchange of views and i think that uh
the kremlin is just kind of saying this
is what we want and you better give it
to us so they have suggested
nato has suggested to continue dialogue
they've talked about confidence building
measures also discussions on
missile defense issues
and
troop placement there's also the the
authority issue of iskander missiles uh
which can be used as nuclear missiles uh
in kaliningrad which is right in the
heart of europe so i think that there
are a lot of areas to discuss i think
that putin is trying it's almost a
chinese concept to win without fighting
so he's trying to to feel his way around
this and see what he can get uh by by
having all these troop movements uh the
ukrainian government has called it
blackmail and you know we we've seen a
lot of dialogue with putin and other
members in the kremlin so from that
point of view he has succeeded but he
doesn't seem to be willing at all to to
have dialogue it's either his way and
the other thing is this is boomeranging
on the kremlin because instead of having
less nato we're seeing more nato uh even
sweden and finland which are neutral
countries are considering joining nato
because this is becoming a very
difficult neighborhood
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests theresa fallon alex titov
and cadre leake
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim jim in the whole team here
bye for now